c'est quoi le bon d'achat
c'est ça ouais c'est ça comment pourquoi
parce que c'était assez big olic au
début et c'était inattendu on savait pas
qu est-ce qu on devait attendre
maintenant les jeunes arrivent ils
connaissent d alchimie entre télé
réalité et finalement c'est juste une
façon de se faire loin et il n'y a plus
un biais d'un prêt en fait c'est un peu
dommage en fait rattraper tout
simplement parce que j'ai grandi avec
les animaux et j'avais une charte que
gucci chanel j'ai vécu avec elle pendant
18 ans éléments le même jeu que ma mère
il ya trois ans au finalement il ya eu
ni gambie
4 en fait mais je peux dire aussi un peu
les deux quelque part parce que
christophe c'est quelqu'un que j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour quelqu'un que
j'ai énormément d'amitié pour à la fois
mais écoute il ya quelque chose qui me
restait à travers la coque
pourquoi il m'a pas choisi pour la roue
de la fortune et il a choisi de victor
et c'est peut-être facilement parce
qu'elle a des atouts que j'en ai pas et
je pense forcément si moi j'étais dans
l'émission mission continue à tous rap
dirai pas ce que moi j'aime pas les
déguisements en fait et le public me le
dit souvent
vous êtes aime tellement naturel
tellement que vous êtes vous avez pas
besoin tout le les activistes ou la
bastille d'un carrasso tout ça dépend
comment tu les utilisent qu'on fait
daf tient tout simplement parce que je
pense que manoir c'est quelqu'un qui a
un énorme coeur c'est quelqu'un qui est
mal utilisée comme moi même à la télé on
ne sait pas comment utiliser manoir au
je pense que c'est un garçon qui a un
très bon acteur
c'est quelqu'un qui a une culture en
fête et c'est un peu dommage
en huit ans parce qu'ils méritent